03:00PM to 06:00PM Eastern
time. Every weekday guy Benson
show dot com online podcast is
free. I think there are some
normal Democrats. Who look at
what happened.
And they see what happened
frankly in 20 16 as well with
the election of Donald Trump
and they recognize that the
progressive movement which
incorporates and includes I
would say much of the political
media.
And dominates the conversation
on social media, especially
twitter which is where a lot of
Democratic politicians hang
out, and seemed to be base
their decisions on what the
twitter mob is saying.
A lot of those folks even left
of center realize how
destructive it is.
I don't know if the Democrats
can pull themselves out of this
problem unless they are willing
to acknowledge.
The reality that most people
recognize in this country
which is that wokeness and
hardcore progressivism and all
of that is alienating
exhausting annoying.
After the Republicans ran an
extremely credible issues based
campaign in Virginia and they
won in a state that has gone
blue. The last decade and a
half.
Republicans were shut out of
statewide office for 12 years,
Joe Biden won it by 10 points
and then the Republicans run
on. Like kitchen, table issues.
They're talking
about inflation. Glenn youngkin
talk about the grocery tax
people are looking around and
seeing what's happening.
The cost of things going up
shortages in labor shortages in
goods.
And the Republicans were
responsive to to that talking
about issues that people
actually care about then of
course education. From
school closures for more than a
year in Virginia public
schools. Thanks to the Democrat
union alliance.
To woke curriculum points.
Racialized curricula.
Critical race theory political
correctness dumbing down
standards equity all of it.
People saw what was going on
they noticed that that's what
James Carville said the last
time we played the clip.
I said this stuff happens.
And people see that that was
his quote what the Democrats.
The hard-core Democrats and
especially their activists
their base and the media what a
lot of them want everyone to
believe the way they
rationalize this the way that
they explain away their pain
through more anger and more
smears and more dishonesty is
to blame voters. For being.
A combination of racist and
stupid.
People to believe that Virginia
which is gone their way right
Virginia's great look at what
Virginia's doing.
>> Until Virginia dares to
not vote Democratic and all of
a sudden it's the Old South.
Back again.
Racism right this is what they
do it just turns on a dime.
So they all of a sudden
Virginia became racist again.
All these parents
are racist making up parental
rights making up critical race
theory making up this stuff
that they are seeing with their
own eyes in their own lives and
they are being told, shouted
out, shouted at.
By some of these media leads by
the activists that they're
crazy they're wrong. They're
racist or.
I think this one is almost as
insulting races would be more
insulting of it still meant
something except they scream
racist about everything all the
time it diminishes.
Because the real thing.
The authentic phenomenon of
racism is abhorrent it is
disgusting. It is appalling.
And it's wrong. To over apply
it.
Like this
the genuine article is terrible
and should be stamped out when
you see it everywhere and
claim that it's everywhere you
lose credibility and people
tune you out
and then as I was going to say
the second part is well maybe
people aren't intentionally
racist. But they're just duped.
Evil Glenn youngkin.
Invented.
To quote barack obama the
trumped-up phony culture war.
A critical race theory.
Which is not phony or trumped
up it's real.
Right or what the sexual
assault in the bathroom that
was covered up in Loudoun
County guess that was phony and
trumped up even though that was
horrific and real. They want us
to believe that people either
have hate in their hearts or
they have been bamboozled.
By these manipulative
Republicans to believe that
something really is happening
when it doesn't and when it
isn't.
I mean what
a way to try to win back voters
that you've lost to immediately
scream at them for being more
on racists. That's what they're
going with. They're writing
columns other the return of the
racist white woman white women
shifted Republican by 15 points
in Virginia.
And rather than saying gosh,
maybe we should think about why
we offended so many mothers.
Why we offended so many female
voters. If they're willing to
call on that as opposed to
birthing people or voters who
men straight.
Instead of doing that they said
look at these white.
I mean white women am I right
and all the actors say.
Well let's all roll our eyes
and shaker has the other man
white women. It's just racism.
That's
what they're doing here as a
form of shaming.
And they're actually learning
none of the actual lessons
that led voters to act the way
that voters did not just white
voters. But a lot of Hispanic
voters and even an increasing
number over time of black
voters, they don't want
that too be reckoned with they
don't want to grapple with that
they don't want that reality to
intrude on
the way that they talk and they
think and they're really I
would say insidious toxic
gross worldview and so what we
get here's a montage of some
gravy and dot com. A
montage of CNN MSNBC other
lefty commentators reacting to
what happened in Virginia.
You know why the Republicans
won in Virginia. The
Republicans know why they won
in Virginia. Voters saw what
happened they looked around
every day they said we're not
happy with the way things are
going. We're not happy with the
Democratic Party, but what a
lot of our colleagues in the
media C is something much
darker cut 23.
>> Glenn youngkin played the
race card for a reason because
he knows it works,
Owen, certain bite voters,
he did stoke white grievance
politics to mobilize the
Republican base is laundered.
>> Trump's really
sort of disgusting flagrant out
racism. He's wrapped in
education education right which
is code for
why parents don't like the idea
of teaching about race that's
the fundamental problem for
these parents and the anti CRT
movement. They don't like the
way whiteness is being
portrayed in these new more
inclusive wasn't this wasn't
about those pocketbook issues.
This was about
how white kids feel talking
about what black kids go
through the subtext of all this
was we can't let these black
and brown people run the
country when young
10 running on critical race
theory that he knew hit a cord
around.
>> The race. I think all the
CRT stuff is trumped up dog
whistling some of it was.
>> Right dog whistle racism.
>> It's just amazing.
And on and on there's a hole
that was 57 seconds we've got
another minute and 5 of all of
it. Whiteness whiteness
I mean these people are out of
their minds. They are obsessed
with skin color and raced it's
really.
It's it's sad
actually, but it's also scary.
As these are the elite of
society who are driving the
conversation of course they're
driving people away from the
Democratic Party into the open
arms of the Republicans.
Who are willing to say no.
We're not going to go along
with this racket.
By the way I love that clip
from what we just played this
the snippet.
The subtext of all this is we
can't let these brac these
black and brown people run the
country. That was one of jewels
of glittering insight that we
heard in
that montage. It's a subject we
can't let these black and brown
people run the country guess
what. On the Republican ticket
in Virginia. There was a black
and a brown person call now be
running the state.
Winsome Sears is the first
black woman elected statewide
ever in Virginia, a black
Jamaican immigrant who came to
this country sign up for the
Marines and said she was
willing to die for this country
because this country is worth
it.
Ran a shelter for
homeless women. You don't hear
much about her in fact I saw
USA Today had a story
about all the candidates of
color making history around the
country. so they left out.
Both of the Republicans who won
in Virginia to statewide
office. Then they updated their
story. After people call them
out on it this close up their
mind only the 2 statewide
officials in the most watched
state in the country this week
who won a black woman and
Hispanic man this didn't make
it into that story. The wrong
type of people of color.
That's why you can have more on
saying dumb dumb things like
that is all about making sure
black and brown people don't
run things literally
literally, the people of
Virginia Republican said we're
going to pick a woman of color
and a Hispanic aging. That
you're going to pick to run the
state. And the take away from
these geniuses who sneer at
idiotic racist is that these
Republicans are just afraid of
black and brown people. You
have to be a total liar
or just broken brain to say
that or just ignore you have no
idea who is on the ticket.
Might use a Republican white
bad.
I mean the fact that they're
talking about whiteness as much
as they are.
I think belies the problem
right critical race theory,
it's all a lie doesn't exist
they made this up it's
misinformation is not true.
We've told you over and over
again evidence why it's not
true. And it's also again you
cannot convince.
That's something totally
fabricated is happening without
some evidence.
Right we quoted in the
Washington Post Latina mom, a
black dad concerned about what
they are seeing on the ground
in the schools in their
communities. There's a black
dad saying his kids brought
home. And Abraham Lincoln
assignment that troubled him
based on the racial angle.
This is a black father so we
start to home-school is kids
because of the indoctrination
he didn't want his kids to go
through and he's left to say
it's all a lie. This critical
race theory is a lie. They're
this isn't happening. And then
they turn right around and they
give the game away.
By spouting all of this
critical race theory stuff they
all believe it
whether they believe it or not
they say it endlessly it is
what their entire worldview is
predicated on.
Racial grievance, critical race
theory and all the buzzwords of
equity an anti racism they're
like this is crazy this this
idiotic racist parents in
believe that there's all racial
in schools that isn't
happening. These stupid racist
wires by the way this is about
whiteness they won because the
whiteness like you guys are
doing the thing that you say
doesn't exist.
>> You are doing
the thing that you say doesn't
exist you go on MSNBC you go on
CNN in front of 10's of viewers
and you talk about whiteness
and you rant about race and dog
whistling and all this stuff
you misconstrue things you lie,
and then you treat people
concerned about exactly that
same garbage being taught in
schools, he said well that's
not even possible is not
happening. It's happening on
your network right now you're
doing it you're doing it.
And your ideological bodies in
the teachers unions are putting
into schools
that is what's happening and
that is what a lot of Americans
are fed up about and that's why
Glenn youngkin Izumi the
governor of Virginia and not
Terry McAuliffe who called it
all a lie and campaign with
Randi Weingarten okay.
>> That's the wake-up call.
And their solution apparently.
Is to call you all
stupid misinformed
misinformation addled racists.
Honestly keep going with
this guys.
Can we drive even more people
out of the Democratic Party.
Police look the Republicans
have their problems and they
drive me crazy and there's some
real flaws and problems in the
Republican Party believe me.
But for the first time in a
while I was excited to vote for
a candidate who was Glenn
youngkin
in Virginia as a Virginia voter
because he's not the things
that they say he is and yet
they just keep saying.
And when you win so people's
intelligence over and over
again.
Finally people get fed up with
it.
By the way
Nicole Wallace. On MSNBC he's
just I mean. He's one of their
anchors on election night.
he flew
an insurrection flag at his
rallies.
Made up. Absolute lie.
Absolute lie, right they say
what Republicans need to do is
repudiate the big lie, and
they'd reject this top youngkin
did that
young King did what they say
they want and what they turned
around and said he didn't do
that. And it's made up stories
about him.
Wright who this Glenn youngkin
he's he's in bed with doctor.
He is Donald Trump is basically
Donald Trump in a vest with a
smile extreme is very
dangerous. Insurrection right
all this stuff, no one believes
that youngkin doesn't campaign
with Trump that McAuliffe
invents a rally.
>> That didn't happen.
And these people all believe
that you are the problem.
>> You and your misinformation
or the problem. When they are
proving the problem and they
are spouting this information.
We had yet was at umea shall
send or that journalist.
He just a left wing activist
being paid by us because she
works at PBS she asked a
question of President Biden
exciting the question really.
This is yesterday.
She had what is your message
for Democrats Democratic
voters, especially black voters
to see Republicans running on
race as Padden lying
about critical race theory and
there were the Democrats don't
have an effective way to push
back on that that's her
question about the Republican
wise on critical race theory.
I mean I could give a point by
point rebuttal as I have on
this show because the same
light of the Democrats tried
and failed with in Virginia.
But this is a journalist paid
for by taxpayers. Asking a
question really just making a
partisan statement.
I have no problem she can have
whatever opinion she wants.
Don't tell me she's a
journalist and don't make me
pay her salary as a journalist.
And last but not
see rolling in with her little
video that she posted on
instagram or whatever this is
so much the problem in Virginia
you see according see is
they were just too moderate
these Democrats running a
moderate campaign it's not
going to work.
see that set personal Terry to
he strike you as a moderate the
way he was running. No.
Screaming about you know
abortion defending late term
abortion bringing in every left
wing Democratic and think of
into the state
attacking parents campaigning
with Randi Weingarten if that's
a moderate campaign good luck.
But if that's what
she believes I see should
campaign for every single
Democrat in the country.
I want her in all 50 states in
2022. If you want hardcore
progressivism to win.
Put your money where your mouth
is boots on the say I
want you there supporting your
fellow Democrats and maybe
you'll do just as well as
Bernie did in the primary or
that socialist in Buffalo when
she lost to a write in
candidate.
Or the defund the police
failures in a bunch of places
the other night. It